Hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo.
Dreimal dürft ihr raten, was passiert ist.
Dreimal dürft ihr raten, was war.
Natürlich hat sich das Game jetzt aufgehängt und ich habe den Dundesnipe verpasst.
Danke, Telekom, ganz toll.
So ein, dass ich sowas überhaupt Provider nennen darf, ey.
Das ist ein Shit, Shitvider oder so.
Shitrider, kein Provider.
Aber, Telekom will Dunde für sich.
Das ist nice, ja.
Tag, Telekom, ey.
Noch mal den Breitbandatlas angucken, ey.
Vielleicht habe ich Glück und das Ding ist gerade in letzter Minute ins Aha gegangen.
Und ist jetzt noch beim Beaten oder so.
Vielleicht habe ich gerade Glück, also ich könnte es, gerade mit ein paar Sekunden könnte ich es packen.
Aber ich glaube es nicht.
Die wollen Dunde für sich.
Haben sie gesniped und haben jetzt wieder mein Internet eingeschaltet.
Oh, nice Graphics.
Moment.
Ist sie noch nicht drinne?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Sehe ich das richtig, dass sie noch nicht drinne war, die Dunde?
Ähm, wisst ihr noch, was das für eine war?
Das war...
Ah, nice.
Telekom.
Bam.
Telekom, jetzt snipe ich euch die Dunde weg.
Easy Snipe.
Achtung Leute, Easy Snipe.
Wahrscheinlich bricht jetzt wieder die Verbindung ab.
Auf.
Come on, Prü.
Ah, hat nicht geklappt.
Hat nicht funktioniert.
Hast du überhaupt Geld?
Ja, äh, äh, Fabian, du wirst lachen.
Ich habe wieder in Velia 160 Mille.
Einfach nur durch sinnloses, äh, äh, rumgegrindet ein bisschen gestern und ein bisschen Dropluck.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht so genau, wo die Kohle herkommt.
Du hast das, das Ding, war im, äh, ich habe Geld eingesammelt aus dem...
aus dem Marketplace, habe gestern, äh, die ganzen Drops noch reingesetzt, die ich auch noch hatte und die ich, ähm, vom, von, von diesen Naga-Dingern gekriegt habe.
Jetzt habe ich wieder 160 Mille.
Äh, das Game macht mal wieder keinen Sound.
So.
Habe genug Telekom gehuldigt.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt können wir uns die Velia-Band anhören.
Beste.
Beste Musik.
Achtung Leute.
Beste, beste Musik.
Beste.
Dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö.
So, ich wurde jetzt mal in Sushi und dann geht es, wird weiter gegrindet.
Welche Musik hörst du so privat?
Äh, hauptsächlich Hardrock, Heavy Metal, sowas in der Richtung.
Hm.
Oder Irish Folk, finde ich auch geil.
So irisches Gefiedel.
Und Haftbefehl, genau, Elbow.
So.
Also ich habe jetzt noch...
Wenn es dann irgendwelche Fragen oder sonst was gibt im Chat, ich brauche jetzt hier noch 5-6 Minuten zum Futtern.
Also jetzt habe ich Zeit.
Jetzt bräuchte ich mal Dance-E-Mails.
Hallo, RevoTM.
Oh, jetzt geht's.
Jetzt, jetzt wird es aber hier technisch.
Sibaro.
Was ist nochmal der Unterschied zwischen Peering und Transit?
Also Peering ist, wenn du zu einem anderen Provider hingehst und sagst, hey, wollen wir uns nicht, wollen wir uns nicht peeren?
Also sprich, du stopfst jetzt ein Kabel.
Von deinem Router zu seinem.
Willig gesagt.
So, Transit ist halt...
Ja, Transit.
Halt von Netz zu Netz so, Transit.
Schlecht erklären.
Von einem zum anderen.
Weil irgendeinem gehört das Netz ja, wo du hin willst.
Wenn du mit dem nicht gepiert bist,
musst du halt...
Das Netz.
Das Paket über andere Wege zu dem Ziel-Netz kriegen, weil du es ja nicht direkt erreichen kannst von dir aus.
Ne, Sibaro, da weiß ich nicht, was dein Cloud-Anbieter mit meint.
Also mit Peering ist normalerweise gemeint, wenn du dich halt direkt oder mehr oder weniger direkt zusammenstöpselst mit anderen Providern.
Peering ist auf jeden Fall das Billigere für dich als Provider.
Weil du direkt von deinem...
Mit deinem Router quasi in das Netz von dem kommst, wo du hin willst, wenn du mit dem gepiert bist.
Da musst du keine Transit-Kosten quasi zahlen.
Oder halt nur das, was es dich kostet.
Was dich selbst kostet.
Ja, Sink, ich warte auf was.
Ich warte drauf, dass ich meinen Sushi fertig gefordert hab.
Vielleicht sollte ich das mal einblenden.
Gibt's an Silvester wieder ein Plants vs. Zombies-Scream?
Mal gucken.
Das schmeckt echt wieder richtig geil, muss ich sagen.
Auch wenn das ja im Prinzip was relativ Simples ist eigentlich.
Ja, ich mein, du hast da ein bisschen Reis.
Da hast du irgendwelche Fischeier oder sowas drumherum.
Und drinnen noch ein bisschen Zeug.
Also, schmeckt doch trotzdem übelst geil.
Sink, was ist denn?
Ja, Do-Ben-Dan direkt.
Klingt nach irgendwelchen...
Irgendeinem Hustensaft oder sowas.
Und diese Rolls mit Krebsfleisch sind nochmal eine Steigerung.
Ne, nicht mit Krebsfleisch, mit Garnelen.
Sind nochmal eine Steigerung.
Schmeckt auch echt geil.
Also, war gut, was wir uns da ausgesucht haben, Freunde.
Weißt du, wie man feststellen kann, ab welchem Knotenpunkt das Internet abbricht?
Also, ist die Frage, was mit Internetabbrechen gemeint ist.
Also, wenn...
Der Weg...
Von dir zu deinem Providerscheinricht funktioniert, kannst du auch nichts großartig feststellen.
Oder wenn's DSL nicht synkt oder so.
Flogstick.
Da kannst du nichts machen.
Also, das kriegst du nicht raus, was da ist.
Wenn du jetzt alle...
Wenn prinzipiell aber alles funktioniert, aber du kannst irgendwas nicht erreichen,
dann kannst du ein Traceroute oder sowas machen.
Und hoffen, dass die Router auf dem Weg ICMP nicht geblockt haben.
Dann siehst du das.
Wo du lang geroutet bist.
Und kannst dann wahrscheinlich auch so ungefähr sagen, wo es halt nicht weitergeht.
Allerdings, wenn was nicht erreichbar ist, sollte eigentlich auch ein Router unterwegs...
Also, wenn's netztechnisch irgendwie grad nicht da ist, unterwegs eine ICMP-Fehlermeldung zurückliefern.
Wenn aber einfach nur der Server nicht antwortet, der Zielserver, kannst du ein Traceroute machen.
Da musst du halt ein bisschen raten danach.
Modem zeigt doch an, dass DSL aus ist.
Nee, da kannst du nichts machen.
Das muss dein Provider klären.
Oh, zum Glück hab ich noch Packung Sojashoes.
Social Eating.
Dein Provider hat keine Ahnung, woran's liegt.
Also, wenn dein DSL nicht synchronisiert, ist dein Provider derjenige, der dafür zuständig ist.
Wenn die sagen, sie haben keine Ahnung.
Das ist unfair.
Ist das vielleicht die Telekom?
So, ich hab jetzt noch drei Stück. Vier Stück.
Danach ist Schluss.
Dann wird weitergecrindet.
Aha, WWPD, erklär uns mal, was da abgeht.
Für alle, die die Leute nicht kennen. Ich kenn die nämlich nicht.
Ha, nice.
Linuxi? Ist das so gedacht, dass man das so ausspricht?
Oder Linuxi?
Linuxi?
Ja, Sushi ist nice.
Ich könnte es jetzt nicht jeden Tag oder jede Woche ein paar Mal essen.
Ja, aber so einmal alle zwei Wochen oder so kann man sich auch eine ordentliche Portion Sushi reinhauen.
Boah, jetzt bin ich aber satt.
Letztes Stück.
So, fertig.
Ich stell das Zeug nochmal raus in die Kühlschrank, dann geht's weiter.
So, auf geht's.
Wird weitergecrindet.
So.
Hab ich dich verschrieben?
Hab ich Sushi geschrieben?
Stimmt, Sushi.
Ja.
Rechtschreibung.
2K18.
2K18, genau. Rechtschreibung in 2K18.
Da ist er.
Ey, Fabian, ist das Timing einfach nur geil oder hast du hier gewartet?
Dass du genau an der Stelle wieder vorbeigekommen bist, gerade als ich umgelockt bin.
Timing, nice.
Voll in Sync, Alter.
Ah.
Lahn.
Wobei, alter, Lahn in BDO ja demnächst eine andere Bedeutung hat.
Bin mal gespannt, wie sie die Klasse ins Deutsche übersetzen.
Ich mein, Tänzerin kann's ja wohl kaum sein, oder?
Die neue Klasse.
Die kriegt da wahrscheinlich so eine richtig hängen gebliebene deutsche Übersetzung.
Genau, Fabian.
Ganz genau.
Das denken die sich bestimmt bei...
Äh, Dings, wie heißen sie noch mal?
Äh, Kakao, WTF.
Wie heißt die Klasse denn auf Englisch?
Ich glaube, Dancer.
Also, Lahn heißt sie auf...
Ich weiß nicht, ob man die überhaupt Lahn ausspricht, ja?
Auf Koreanisch.
Und Dancer heißt sie auf Englisch.
Beispiel Lahn besser.
Alter, Lahn.
Ähm, so, und...
Die machen bestimmt wieder so eine ganz abgedrehte Übersetzung.
So.
Doch, ich weiß, wie die's übersetzen.
100 Pro.
Wetten, dass das Ding Schwert-Tänzerin heißt?
Das ist RPG-technisch und, ähm...
So vom Fantasy-Setting her wird das passen.
Das Ding heißt Schwert- oder Klingentänzer, wird das heißen auf Deutsch.
100 Pro.
Das passt nämlich zur Klasse und klingt nicht so bescheuert wie Tänzerin.
Mal abwarten.
Oder aber es heißt...
Ganz anders.
Und wir fragen uns alle, was ist das?
Dann kommen sie...
Dann kommen dann die Leute wieder an.
Was ist denn die beste Waffe für die Black Mage?
Ne, Fabian?
Wobei, die Leute übersetzen das dann wahrscheinlich wieder zurück.
Und sagen dann, was ist die beste Klasse für Plate Dancer?
Oder sowas.
Oder was?
Oh ja, ich muss auch mal Zeug ins Camel laden.
Oh, was ist das für eine Musik gerade?
Moment.
Das muss mal ein bisschen leiser gemacht werden.
Hallo Patrick.
Your mount is too heavy.
Das ist mir doch egal.
Call Peter.
Kakao.
Ruf Peter an, wenn mein mount too heavy ist.
Mir ist das egal.
Du willst ja fail teleport.
Da war überhaupt nichts da.
Jetzt haben wir hier mal Damage Boost.
Jetzt geht's ab.
Jetzt wird Sven's gerackt.
Die Fogans waren abgemurkst.
Das ist gar kein gescheites Wort für eingefallen.
Ich wollte eigentlich sowas sagen wie abgebashed.
Aber das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Geschlitzt werden sie.
Geschnetzelt.
Das erinnert mich daran,
dass, wie die Games da früher versucht hat,
alles irgendwie einzudeutschen.
Das war auch geil, ne?
Die haben ja damals nicht geschrieben
zu Diablo 2 und sowas.
Haben ja nicht geschrieben irgendwie Hack and Slay, sonstwas.
Die haben damals sowas geschrieben wie
Die wilde Monsterhatz geht weiter.
Oder sowas wie
Die aufregende Monsterhatz geht in eine zweite Runde.
Das war doch was.
Wo verkauft man am besten die Sachen,
die ich hab?
Zwar einen Händler gefunden,
aber dort kann ich nichts verkaufen.
Mein Inventar geht über.
Die Sachen, die du behalten möchtest,
legst du in dein Storage
in einem der Städte.
Ansonsten kannst du eigentlich
fast alles bei so ziemlich jedem Händler
verkaufen an Trashloot.
Es ist eigentlich wurscht, welche Händler.
Und wenn du Sachen hast,
die du verkaufen willst, kannst du sie
beim Marketplace
reinsetzen und vielleicht kauft sie jemand.
Bam!
Shracked.
Da ist ein.
Vor allem, den müssen wir picken, glaube ich.
Der macht unsere
Rotation kaputt.
Können den einfach outcryen,
dann kann er nichts machen.
Der macht Damage, das wird nichts.
Sagt aber, wenn er Damage macht.
Wir machen auch Damage.
Aber der macht wahrscheinlich an uns
mehr Damage.
Pogons.
Der muss gebasht werden.
Der guckt mich so an.
Der auch.
Wir müssen übrigens
am Wochenende auch mal Scrolls machen.
Servona, welches
Level bist du denn und wo bist du?
Und was willst du verkaufen?
Vielleicht sind es ja Items, die man nicht verkaufen kann.
Manche Sachen, die man in Rewards hat
und ich glaube auch manche Questbelohnungen
kann man nicht verkaufen.
Woher bekommst du einen Pinguin?
Die waren mal in den
Daily Rewards drinnen.
Die waren mal in den Rewards drinnen, ansonsten kannst du
im Marketplace gucken oder Pay2Win.
Moment, wo ist der Fabian da hinten
am Start?
Ah, WTF.
Ich habe die Rotation zerstört.
Schön desynced.
Die Mops.
Servona, du musst mit dem Händler reden.
Ist das denn überhaupt ein Händler, der Zeugs verkauft?
Wo man Zeugs kaufen kann?
Normalerweise
klickst du den Händler an,
gehst davor, drückst R, gehst auf Shop,
klickst auf Shop
und dann
kriegst du
angezeigt, was der hat.
Falls
dein Inventar nicht aufgeht, kannst du I drücken,
aber ich glaube das geht automatisch auf.
Aber so in Details, falls
da jetzt wirklich irgendwas nicht funktioniert,
muss ich dir sagen,
ich bin auch Noob in dem Game.
Ja guck, der Chat, der kennt sich aus.
Vielleicht kannst du mal sagen, was du
verkaufen willst, dann kann dir bestimmt einer im Chat
helfen, ob man das verkaufen kann.
Es gibt einige Items, die kann man nicht
an Händler geben.
Wenn dein Inventar nicht erscheint, drück mal I.
Aber in BDO
ist einiges nicht so offensichtlich.
Da braucht man immer ein bisschen,
bis man da reinkommt.
Aber man sollte sich nicht so sehr davon frustrieren lassen.
Dafür hat das Game
halt auch eine gewisse Tiefe.
Und nicht nur der Geldbeutel.
Bam!
Tracked.
Oh, der Typ ist geflexort
da vorne, hast du gesehen?
Oder ist der negativ, Karma?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Er war zumindest rot, der Typ, der
da vorne rumgelaufen ist.
Schön desynced, die Mobs.
Ach so, ja
wenn du mit einem Trade-Typ redest,
da kannst du nichts verkaufen. Genau, du musst
zu halt einem Shop, zu irgendeinem Shop.
Ist vollkommen egal, ob es da,
wo es Tränke gibt, ob du zum Stable
gehst oder so, halt irgendwo was,
wo du Sachen kaufen kannst.
BDO-Fail, ja.
Das ist auch sowas, das könnte man
schon ein bisschen klarer machen.
Oh, Buffwood, ich glaub hier war er mal.
Ihr müsst mich mal mehr
anschreien, wenn ich Buffwood vergesse.
Lull, Max,
Snoop, Max, Buffwood, Lull, irgendwas.
Hehe.
Ja, Savona, einige Sachen in BDO
sind nicht unbedingt auf den ersten Blick
immer so klar.
Ich hab letztens in meiner Fritzbox,
weil wir gerade wieder
einen schönen Crash hatten wegen der Telekom,
hab ich in meiner Fritzbox eingestellt,
allein schon, dass es dafür einen Regler gibt,
ne, gibt in der Fritzbox
den Regler Verbindungsstabilität.
Kann man einstellen
auf Stabilität
oder Performance, warum auch immer
es sowas überhaupt gibt, ja.
Hab ich mir jetzt eingebildet,
das bringt was, aber es war wahrscheinlich
einfach nur Glück, dass es die letzten Tage
nicht abgekackt ist.
Kack, Telekom.
Echt Kacklan.
Das hat jetzt auch einfach mal so 40 Viewer gefressen,
das Ganze.
Ungefähr.
Skillpoint, yeah.
Ich hab dich endlich gefunden.
Ach nee, nicht mich, endlich einen gefunden.
Ja, nice.
Du kannst auch auf der Map gucken.
Du kannst auch auf der Map gucken, oder du gehst
hier oben drauf, guck mal da, wo die Lupe ist,
und klickst hier was an,
hier zum Beispiel
Händler, klickst da an,
und wenn du jetzt nicht grad in der Wüste bist, da wo ich
bin, dann kriegst du sogar
automatisch den Pfad markiert,
wie du zu dem nächstgelegenen
Händler kommst.
Und wenn du ganz faul bist, drückst du Autorun
und läufst sogar automatisch hin.
Wo ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen DSL
und ADSL? Keiner.
Also das A ist dafür, dass
es asynchron ist, aber das Asynchron
zieht sich da drauf, dass du quasi mehr Download als Upload hast.
Wie du die
Bandbreite verteilst, ja,
ist egal.
Irgendwie haben sich die Provider halt mal eingeredet,
dass...
Asymmetrisch, ja, hast recht, Sibaro.
Ja, ich krieg das
auch nicht alles immer perfekt hin, ja.
In der IHK-Prüfung hättest du jetzt schon gepunktet.
Irgendwann
haben sie sich halt mal eingeredet, die Leute
brauchen viel mehr Download als Upload,
was ja prinzipiell auch stimmt,
denn nur nach 15
Mbps braucht man
mehr Download als Upload.
Content Creators brauchen
natürlich auch Upload,
aber das sind ja die wenigsten.
Allerdings hat es teilweise
echt groteske Ausmaße angenommen.
Wenn man sich überlegt, dass
man jetzt von Unity Media
kriegt man jetzt
400 Mbps mit Down,
400 und 10 ab.
Und das sind halt Verhältnisse,
die sind absolut lächerlich, ja.
Niemand braucht 400
Mbps mit Down, so wirklich.
So, ein schöner Kompromiss
wäre, sagen wir mal,
also schön wäre 400 Down, 400 ab.
Äh, sorry, 400 Down, 40 ab.
Wäre schön, wenn sie das machen würden.
Natürlich noch besser wäre 400 Down, 400 ab.
Wobei das wahrscheinlich
nicht jede Leitung hergibt.
Oder aber sie würden sowas
machen wie
250.
50 ab, 200 hoch.
Das wäre gut. Da würden sie auch schön
L-Konkurrenz machen.
Easy. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum sie da nicht auf die Idee kommen.
550.
Ja, das ist schön. Das ist gut.
Damit kann man leben.
Gibt es aber wahrscheinlich, wir haben uns
das ja gestern angeguckt, die Landkarte in Deutschland
mit Internetausbau.
Ähm, wahrscheinlich
gibt es dieses Vodafone 500
beziehungsweise 500
runter, 50 hoch, wahrscheinlich
an zwei Standorten weltweit oder so.
Oder deutschlandweit.
Du hast 550.
Nice.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch das Twitch.
Also ich habe auch wie, ähm,
wer war das, der im Chat das eben geschrieben hat?
Wie
Kapuzenboy.
Oder Kapuzenboy. Aber ist das gleiche.
VDSL 100, also 100 runter, 40 ab.
Schon mal ein riesen
Fortschritt im Vergleich zu dem Unity Media Crap.
Und der Unity Media Crap war vor ein paar
Jahren noch ein riesen Fortschritt zum damaligen
Telekom Crap. Aber
eigentlich alles Crap.
550 ist großflächig
verfügbar.
Okay, Moment. Ich gucke jetzt mal auf dem zweiten
Bildschirm, ob es bei mir verfügbar ist.
Vodafone
Verfügbarkeit.
Das gucke ich mir jetzt mal an.
Vodafone DSL
Verfügbarkeitscheck. Prüfen.
Straßenhausnummer, okay.
Prüfen.
Jetzt bin ich ja,
jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Es rödelt, die Seite rödelt.
An ihrer Adresse ist
DSL zu Hause verfügbar.
Nö, ist bei mir nicht verfügbar.
Bei mir ist verfügbar Vodafone
Red Internet und Telefon
100 runter, 40 ab. Das ist wahrscheinlich
ein Resale von der Telekom.
Oder gibt es da eine spezielle
Adresse, wo man
das prüfen muss und nicht bei der normalen
Verfügbarkeitsprüfung von Vodafone.
Ja gut.
Ist doch egal. Ich mach Verfügbarkeitscheck
bei Vodafone.
Der Verfügbarkeitscheck sollte doch wohl
alle Technologien mit einbeziehen.
Oder gibt es einen extra Kabel
Verfügbarkeitscheck.
Guck ich nochmal.
Ich guck mal.
Verfügbarkeit von Internet und Telefon
Angebote überprüfen.
Im Kabelglasnetz.
Prüfen.
Verfügbarkeit prüfen.
Zu den Angeboten.
Prüfung abgeschlossen.
Nö.
Das zeigt mir nur an
maximalen Red Internet und Telefon 100
DSL.
Gibt es bei mir wohl nicht.
Wäre eine Option aber auf jeden Fall.
Ach war das Kabel
Deutschland.
Früher. Ich bin noch in Hessen.
Da ist noch Unity Media am Start.
Dann gibt es das da natürlich nicht.
Fehl um 28. Dann hast du Glück.
Dass du in einem der Gebiete, wo uns die ordentlich
ausgebaut sind. Weil es ist meistens so,
wenn man in irgendeinem CAF, dann mal
einen ordentlichen Anschluss bekommt.
Dann bekommt man meistens noch einen richtig ordentlichen Anschluss.
Weil dann haben sie halt da was hingebaut.
Und dann sind halt alle Leute so nah dran, dass sie fast das
Maximale kriegen von dem was es gibt.
Ja und Sibaro hat recht.
Kabelglasfaser ist Schwachsinn.
Im Backend ist das eh alles Glasfaser.
Aber
Die Kabel, das Kabelnetz
Das ist ein Coax Kabel.
Da ist nix mit Glasfaser.
Sollen die auch auf einmal herkommen.
Die haben sich ja nicht in mein Haus gebeamt unten.
Wie ist eigentlich die Stadt?
Die Stabilität bei DSL vs. Kabel
Wenn das nicht irgendwie
am Limit betrieben wird und das letzte
ausgereizt wird.
Die Provider machen das
eigentlich so, dass es doch schon
meistens eher auf der sicheren Seite sind.
Macht keinen Unterschied.
Ich würde sagen die Probleme die es gibt, gibt es nicht
wirklich mit dem Kabel.
Sondern mit dem was
Unity Media zum Beispiel damit veranstaltet.
Zum Beispiel quasi
mehr Anschlüsse verkaufen.
Wenn die Kapazität nicht reicht.
Indem man sich das schön rechnet.
Oder ihr komisches
Krückenkonstrukt DSLite.
Also
Dual Stack Lite.
Ist auch so ne krasse
Krücke.
Also mit Dual Stack Lite.
Weiß nicht ob ich das schon mal erklärt habe.
Also erstmal, was ist mit Dual Stack gemeint?
Hi, eine Frage.
Ist Wizard oder Witch besser?
Ich würde sagen, nimmt sich nicht viel.
Aber Wizard ist noch ein
Ticken universeller.
Also was ist Dual Stack?
Dual Stack ist ganz simpel gesagt,
man kriegt eine IPv4 und eine IPv6
Adresse. Deswegen Dual Stack.
Weil man beides kriegt.
So und Unity Media weiß
natürlich, dass noch nicht alles über
IPv6 verfügbar ist.
Deswegen müssen sie die Leute irgendwie
Verbindungen
erlauben zu IPv4 Adressen.
Für den Fall, dass es halt eben
die jeweilige Seite nicht über IPv6
erreichbar ist. Das müssen sie, sonst
funktioniert ja auf einmal Teile vom Internet nicht mehr.
Allerdings anstatt so einen ordentlichen
Dual Stack zu machen. Wahrscheinlich
weil sie schlicht und ergreifend nicht genug Adressen haben.
Haben sie sich sowas ausgedacht
wie DSLite mit
Carrier Crate Nut.
Und das ist der größte Shit ever.
Das heißt du kriegst gar
keine IPv4 Adresse, sondern
dein IPv4
Zugang wird getunnelt über
IPv6 zu Unity Media.
Wo du dir dann
eine IPv4 Adresse mit
mehreren Unity Media Kunden teilst.
Also quasi NAT, was dein
Router normalerweise daheim macht, machen die dann
halt Carrier Crate auf
Provider Seite.
So und da hast du dann das Problem,
dass dann irgendwie keine Ahnung
50 Unity Media Kunden sich, ich weiß nicht
wie viele es wirklich sind, die gleiche
IPv4 Adressen
teilen, was
zu massig Problemen führt
und was dazu führt, dass man keine
Ports weiterleiten kann, weil
naja, du kannst dich ja schlecht auf einen Provider
Router einloggen um da Ports weiterzuleiten.
So ist das.
Deswegen ist es der größte Scheiß
den sie sich überhaupt ausgedacht haben.
Frosch 68
aber eh klar.
Oder Akle, Akle ist es, ne?
Aber Akle. Deswegen kriegt ihr
wenn ihr Unity Media habt und DSLite
kriegt ihr nie auf eurer
Xbox angezeigt,
dass ihr offenes NAT habt, was auch so eine bescheuerte
Bezeichnung ist. Ja?
Ihr sollt nie bei euch irgendwas daheim
von außen erreichen. Geht nicht.
Technisch nicht
drinnen.
Erstmal eine richtige Frage.
Ich hab
110, also
100-10 VDSL
bei einem kleinen Anbieter
nicht Telekom. In der Fritzbox steht
Leitungskapazität 137
aber da schwankt manchmal. Wie kommt das?
Ich geh mal
davon aus, dass die Fritzbox
die muss sich ja synken
mit
also das DSL Modem
in der Fritzbox
muss sich ja synken mit dem
DSL LAM
oder wie auch immer man das Ding ausspricht
vom Provider. Also das Ding was quasi
auf der Straße irgendwo ist.
Oder in
irgendeinem Häuschen.
Und da wird die Fritzbox wahrscheinlich
einfach gucken, was hat die Leitung
für eine Dämpfung und
schätzt dann, was würde sie dann hergeben.
Aber wenn du bei deinem Provider
100-10
hast, wirst du wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr kriegen.
Die Leitung würde halt lauter
Fritzbox mehr hergeben.
DSLAM heißt das.
Aber noch
besser ist DSLAM.
DSLAM, das ist dann, das hört sich so an
als schlägt hier mal irgendjemand.
Und was hast
du heute gemacht? Spezialattacke.
DSLAM.
Das hört sich an wie irgendein krasser Wizardmove hier.
Guck hier, das ist der DSLAM.
Bam.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall gut, wenn die Fritzbox anzeigt,
die Leitung könnte laut ihr
noch mehr. Fabian hat
zu mich eigentlich gehostet, weil hier sind einige Leute,
die kenne ich nur bei dir aus dem Stream.
Hä?
TF?
Ich dachte, du hast mich gleich gehostet.
Ich hoste dich ja auch ab und zu mal.
Und so Leute wie Bluebash oder so, die habe ich bisher
nur bei dir gesehen.
Aber Sibaro, ich sehe schon, du bist für deine IHK-Prüfung
bestens gerüstet.
Wann ist sie eigentlich?
Wann ist es denn soweit?
2019 im März.
Also bist du jetzt quasi
im zweiten Jahr, wenn man so will.
Dann, also
nächstes Jahr
quasi.
Und was lernst du genau?
Feezy oder
was machst du?
Wie lange bin ich denn eigentlich schon on?
Es wird ja gefühlt schon wieder ewig.
Ach fuck, das sieht man also nicht mit
Uptime, weil ja der Stream dank
wieder abgekackt ist.
Wann habe ich denn angefangen?
Ich denke 14.30
oder so? 15 Uhr?
15 Uhr habe ich angefangen.
Also gleich wieder 5 Stunden.
Oh, ich wusste ja.
Black Spirit.
Hoffentlich habe ich genug
Energie noch.
Sibaro, siehst du,
ich bin ja froh, wenn die Videos
Leuten was bringen.
Jetzt gleich was fressen.
Schlag dann kurz auf den Berser um.
Falls du danach noch
weitermachen willst.
Ich habe theoretisch auch genug
gecrined für heute.
Aber wenn du noch weitermachen willst,
bin ich auch noch dabei dann.
Dreieinhalb Stunden bis jetzt, okay.
Bin ich so spät erst on gekommen?
Irgendwie 16 Uhr?
16 Uhr, 16.30 oder?
Ich dachte, ich war
um 15 Uhr schon on.
Reicht mir dann auch, okay.
Aber wir haben heute mehr als unser
Soll erfüllt.
Vielleicht mache ich noch eine Nacht
gleich exp Naga
Kreiselcrined oder sowas.
Moment, renn ich denn überhaupt
hin gerade? Lol.
Ich meine, es ist ja schon quasi in
vier Ingame Stunden wieder Nacht.
Das könnte man eigentlich nochmal mitnehmen.
Dann hätten wir nämlich 85%.
Also locker.
Wobei es mir ehrlich gesagt
auch langt.
Castellan, ja, es ist zu empfehlen.
Das schöne ist ja, du kannst das Game kaufen, spielen,
und musst eigentlich nichts an
Abo-Gebühren oder Shop-mäßig bezahlen.
Erst wenn du dir denkst, hey,
ich will es jetzt ernsthaft spielen, dann ist Überlegung wert,
ob man sich manche Sachen kauft.
Und selbst wenn du das nur so
Casual-mäßig spielen willst, wie ich,
dass du auch mal zwischendurch
ein paar Monate gar nicht spielst,
oder nur ab und zu ist das gut, du kriegst einmal am Tag
einen dick...
Was geht mit dem ab?
Du kriegst einmal am Tag einen dicken
XP-Boost, kannst du dir aussuchen,
ob du für eine Stunde 200%
XP haben willst, oder ich glaube für zwei Stunden 100%.
Und
den kannst du dann
eine Stunde am Tag grinden.
Oder wenn du das nicht machen willst,
kannst du immerhin einmal einloggen und dir
einen Login-Reward abholen.
Also ich finde, die haben das ganz gut geschafft,
dass du, auch wenn du
nicht 24-7 spielst,
nicht total hinten dran gelangst.
Also es ist ein super, super Spiel,
weil man das so ein bisschen Casual-mäßig nebenbei spielt.
Und vor allem,
wenn man ein krasser Craft-Life-Skiller ist,
ist das Game geil.
Es gibt ja Leute, die machen den ganzen Tag nichts anderes
als processen.
Ne, Abo-Gebühren hast du nicht.
Du musst das Spiel einmal kaufen,
dann kannst du spielen, so viel du willst.
Wenn du es halt dann ein bisschen
länger spielst, manche Sachen sind sinnvoll
zu kaufen,
hier Inventar-Erweiterungen zum Beispiel,
Gewichts-Erweiterungen, dass du mehr tragen kannst,
Storage-Plätze,
...
und vielleicht ein paar Pads,
die für dich Loot aufheben.
Also zumindest, also
ein Pad an sich ist schon echt praktisch.
So dieses Loot von Hand aufheben ist
saumäßig nervig.
Weiß jemand, wie groß das Spiel
entpackt ist? Ich würde mal sagen 60 GB
oder so.
Das Spiel ist richtig fett mittlerweile.
28 nur,
das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Echt? Das ist ja richtig klein.
Guck mal,
die kriegen ein komplettes MMO
in 27 MB,
aber das neue COD hat 65 oder sowas.
Lull.
Und jetzt dürfen wir uns ja überlegen,
welches Game hat mehr Inhalt.
Also man kommt in BDO als Casual auf jeden Fall
voran, das Spiel hat aber eine gewisse
Tiefe und auch einen
ein bisschen schwierigen Einstieg
jetzt nicht vom spielerischen her,
sondern bis man durchblickt.
Weil es gibt halt sehr viele Sachen
und es ist nicht so offensichtlich und klar.
Wir hatten beispielsweise jemand im Chat,
der ist zum NPC gegangen, wo Händler dran standen
und hat sich gewundert, warum er nichts verkaufen kann.
War eben gerade im Chat.
Solche Dinger halt.
Da ist in BDO ein bisschen schwierig
durchzublicken am Anfang.
Aber wenn man da einmal den Dreh raus hat, geht das.
Wie gesagt, ich bin ja auch Noob in dem Game.
Mich würden mal
Abozahlen, äh nicht Abozahlen,
Spielerzahlen interessieren.
Also nicht erstellte Accounts, sondern wirklich aktive
Spiele abends in den unterschiedlichen Regionen.
Also Korea, NA, Russland
und EU.
Würde mich mal interessieren,
wie viele Leute da BDO spielen.
Oder gibt es
sowas? Wisst ihr das?
Ja, ich würde sagen, Steam ist aber auch nur
ein Bruchteil davon.
Also es ist schwierig zu sagen.
Aber wenn man sich anguckt, dass die Channel
abends fast alle Crowded sind und sie haben die schon
erweitert, deutet
es ja eher darauf hin, dass das Spiel aktuell
wächst und das nicht gerade langsam.
Diese Channels
sind ja alle neu hier unten. Ne, Moment.
Die da.
Hier sind ja neue dazugekommen.
Und vor allem für Steam
sind ja auch neue Channels dazugekommen.
Für die Steam Leute, die da
anfangen für den ersten Monat
oder so.
Also für mich sieht es so aus, als wächst das Spiel
aktuell sogar ziemlich schnell.
Und mich würde mal interessieren, welche
Regionen am meisten Spiele online haben.
Zu ihrer jeweiligen Primetime.
Kennt ihr?
Das guck ich mir später an.
Oder ich guck mal rein.
Vielleicht ist es was, was wir uns im Stream angucken können.
BUFFT!
Die schreiben auch teilweise komisches Zeug.
Anzahl der Abenteuer, Anzahl der Charaktere.
Ja, das ist immer so nichtssagend.
Das ist quasi Anzahl der erstellten Helden,
Anzahl der erstellten Accounts und so.
Sag mal her, was gibt es denn sonst noch?
Ne, da
erkennt man glaube ich dann wirklich viel draus.
Spielst du nur Mage?
Ich habe noch einen Bersi.
Aber
Wizard ist mein Main.
Wizard Main
by the way.
Nachdem ich
mich jetzt ja in letzter Overwatch
Season quasi so hervor
getan habe durch meine absoluten
huge Mercy Plays,
habe ich mir gedacht, muss ich hier auch mal eine Klasse
in BDO spielen, die meinen Skill Level
angemessen ist.
Und da blieb
eigentlich nur Wizard.
Bershin.
Wobei ich glaube ja, die richtigen Mercy
Mains,
die würden hier eher Walküre spielen.
Wenn Mercy mal
genervt wird in Overwatch, also
richtig hardcore, dass die ganzen
Mercy Main Grills sagen, ey ich habe keinen
Bock mehr auf Overwatch, dann spielen die BDO Walküre.
Ich sag's euch.
Dark hat jetzt eine Free2Play Option.
Ernsthaft.
Ist ihnen das jetzt nach 13 Jahren
oder so auch schon aufgefallen?
Dass das für das Game und die Spielerzahlen
mal nicht schlecht wäre.
Und wie sieht die aus?
Insomniac, du kannst dir den
glaube ich immer noch kaufen, das geht.
Kannst Pay2Win machen.
Ich guck mir gleich mal
Dark Free2Play an.
Das muss
ich mir gleich mal durchlesen, was sie sich da ausgedacht
haben.
Könnt ihr mal einen krassen
RR11
Kobol Skalde mal wieder spielen.
Bester.
Kobol Skalde.
Nur die Pros haben Kobol Skalde gespielt.
Haben dich alle
für Schamanen gehalten. Hast du die
gereckt?
Ich will nicht wissen, wie viele Spielstunden ich auf dem habe.
Aber die meisten Spielstunden habe ich auf dem Clary,
definitiv. Clary und Kaba
habe ich die meisten Spielstunden
gefolgt von Skalde.
Okay, hat eh keiner eine Ahnung, worüber
ich rede, aber. Ich muss mal nachdenken.
Dann machen wir die Free2Play Option für Dark angucken.
Lohnt sich das
große Black Desert Paket?
Cryptoker, sag mal, was da drin ist.
Kann ich dir vielleicht
helfen, ob sich das lohnt.
Lass Clary
Sorg bashen. Fabian, ich glaube nicht,
dass es ein neuer Server ist.
Wenn es ein neuer Server wäre, könnten
wir das machen, aber ansonsten
haben wir dann quasi
sind wir gegen die
RR14 Typen da am Start.
In SG.
Okay.
Kein Bock mehr auf Witch, kann ich gar nicht.
Ich finde, Wizard spielt sich übelst entspannt.
Du drückst einfach deine
drei Spells. GG, easy win.
Zweimal Value
Pack, zehnmal Eleon's
Blessing, ein Tier fünf
Horse, zweimal, oh
Pet. Pet ist gut.
Characterslot
Expansion,
Inventory Slot,
Pferdeflöte, Haus Decorations
braucht kein Mensch. Ja, die Hälfte
davon ist ganz nett.
Was kostet das mehr im Vergleich zum
normalen? Da kann man sich ja relativ einfach
gucken, ob sich das sogar lohnt.
Was kostet denn das
normale und was kostet das Special Pack?
Also die Inventarerweiterung
ist gut, das Pet ist auch gut,
das Value Pack ist auch brauchbar,
aber das kann man sich alles relativ günstig so kaufen.
Fünf Euro zu
25, ich glaube, das nimmt sich kaum
was. Ich denke
mal zwei Value Packs,
zwei Value Packs,
die Inventarerweiterung und das Zeug.
Wahrscheinlich lohnt sich's,
aber ich glaube, es nimmt sich nicht viel.
Also die
Value Packs sind auf jeden Fall praktisch
und natürlich auch die Inventarerweiterung
und das Zeug. Siehste, genau wie es
die Leute schreiben im Chat.
Kann man sich ja ganz gut ausrechnen.
So schlimm ist das schon.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was der Kram kostet.
Ich kauf mir das zwar,
aber nachdem sie ja
RL Geld mal wieder, so
schön abstrahiert haben
mit
Daumen Cash
und Pearls und sowas, wo du dann
überhaupt nicht mehr weißt, was was ist
in quasi echter Währung.
Also die Value Packs sind
aber auf jeden Fall praktisch.
Und auch
hier die Inventarerweiterung, das Pet und so.
Was ist denn für ein Pet?
Vielleicht ist es ja auch eines
der geilen Pets.
Bist du in einer Gilde? Ja, ich bin hier
in GG Exilium.
Schreit jetzt auch zurück.
Mount ist immer noch too heavy.
Und Peter hat auch noch nicht angerufen.
Achmet.
Hüpft drauf.
Krasser Wizard.
Am Wochenende
vor allem am Wochenende müssen wir Skrulls machen.
Massig.
Okay, das sind nur die normalen Pets.
Ich dachte, du hast vielleicht Glück.
Und...
Es ist ja irgendwie so ein Igel dabei
oder sowas. Der Igel ist über...
Der übelste...beste Pet.
Wenn man...wenn man Gathern will
und sowas sammeln...also wenn man
Lifeskill-Zeug machen will.
Was bringt denn so ein Value Pack?
Also, erst mal muss ich sagen,
ich bin auch ein ziemlicher Video-Noob.
Auch wenn sich das im Stream irgendwie
so anhört, als hätte ich von irgendwas
große Ahnung. Habe ich nicht.
Aber was ein Value Pack bringt, kann ich dir zeigen.
Man kann nämlich einfach oben drüber gehen.
Irgendwo. Da. Das bringt ein Value Pack.
Inventar...
Ich muss mal dem Fireman hinterher reiten.
Boah, ich finde den Weg
auch so zurück.
Also, du kannst dir das Ingame im Pearl Shop angucken.
Du kriegst Inventarplätze.
Kriegst Storageplätze. Ich zeig's dir gleich.
Wenn ich den Fireman
überholt hab. Dann zeig's dir.
Ähm...
Ich glaub, das Food
ist wieder dran, ne? Nein. Fuck.
Das hab ich verdrückt.
Falsches Food. Es wird mal Zeit, dass ich mal
einen Food-Timer programmier.
Ich hab's ja schon angedroht, dass wir wieder ein bisschen
Programming-Stream machen.
So, jetzt zeig ich's dir. Also, das Value Pack
bringt, ähm...
Du kriegst 16 Inventarplätze.
16 Storageplätze in der Stadt.
Du kriegst mehr XP.
Das ist wirklich praktisch.
Du kannst, ähm...
Ohne zum Node Manager laufen
zu müssen, Sachen upgraden.
Du kannst mehr
tragen.
Und du sparst ein bisschen Geld
im Marketplace.
Ja, und du kannst dein Aussehen beliebig
oft ändern, während das Value Pack aktiv ist.
Ich hab's ja gestern
schon mal gesagt.
Ähm...
Was echt praktisch wäre, wäre so ein Overlay.
Was dir anzeigt...
Also, es geht natürlich nur, wenn BDO
im Window-Modus läuft.
So ein halbtransparentes Fenster als
Overlay, was dir anzeigt, welches Buff-Food
du jetzt nehmen musst.
Sowas dürfte relativ simpel zu
programmieren sein.
Wenn man es ein bisschen advanced macht mit,
dass das Programm nachguckt, was du schon
aktiviert hast und so.
Das könnten wir machen im Stream.
Das Kristallsymbol neben der
Leiste.
Meinst du das hier? Das mit den 64% drin.
Das ist quasi...
Wenn du Overwatch spielst oder
an MOBA oder sowas, ist es quasi deine Ultimate.
Könnte man sagen.
Krass.
Ahmed ist Level 5.
Yeah!
Ahmed PogChamp.
Wie der Sand aufploppt.
Sieht aber richtig freudig schlecht aus.
Ja, also wie gesagt,
der Kristall ist deine Ultimate-Fähigkeit.
Du hast...
Also als Wizard
hast du auf diesem Spell hier
ein Ultimate drauf.
Dem da.
Dann macht er...
Steht ja oben da, Black Spirit Rage 100%.
Dann macht er mehr Damage.
Das ist so ein AE.
Oder aber du kannst auch
die klassischen Spells nehmen
und dich buffen oder deine Mitspieler buffen.
Das ist halt wie gesagt dann...
Dein Ultimate.
Deine Ultimate-Fähigkeit.
Die Map zu dieser Art hat lange gedauert.
Ich glaube, das hat wirklich lange gedauert.
Auch wenn das...
Das sieht halt nur so Fail aus, weil das so aufploppt.
Das ist schon ziemlich durchdacht.
Du hast ja hier
in der Wüste auch Händler-Karawanen
und jede Menge Zeug. Also das ist schon durchdacht.
Es sieht halt scheiße aus, wie das Ganze so aufploppt.
Und ursprünglich
habe ich ja sogar mal zum Fabian gesagt...
Ich weiß noch, ich habe es installiert.
Du kannst dich bestimmt auch noch daran erinnern.
Ich habe es installiert, habe mir einen Wizard erstellt.
Oder einen Bersi erstellt.
Ich glaube einen Wizard habe ich mir erstellt.
Und in der Startstadt
bin ich zwei Meter aus der Stadt gelaufen
und habe gesagt, Fabian, ich kann das nicht spielen.
Hä, warum?
Ja, die Pop-Ups und so, ich kann das nicht spielen.
Das halte ich nicht aus.
Was wir machen können,
ist gleich nochmal
das Game auf 100%
also auf Grafik
auf 100%
also auf High
Grafik-Settings stellen
und nochmal den High-End-Modus einschalten.
Und dann mal gucken, wie es aussieht.
Das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Aber ich kann euch sagen, es sieht zwar besser aus,
aber die Pop-Ups sind nur noch noch nerviger.
Fabian, könntest du machen.
Wie viele Leute sind denn da,
die das interessieren würde,
wie die BDO-Welt so aussieht?
Ich kann das nicht mit leveln.
Für heute.
Ich könnte euch noch ein bisschen die Welt zeigen,
wenn ihr wollt.
Weil ich weiß ja noch ungefähr,
welche Sachen ich selbst geil gefunden habe.
Ich habe es jetzt ja schon oft gesagt,
ich bin ja auch noch übelster Noob in dem Game.
Wenn ihr Interesse habt,
wollen wir uns die Welt noch ein bisschen angucken.
Soll ich das mal ein bisschen zeigen?
Weil die Welt ist wirklich geil.
Und sie haben eine Sache geschafft,
das hat noch kein anderes MMO geschafft,
was ich bisher gesehen habe.
Sie haben es geschafft,
dass die Spielwelt überall belebt ist.
Ich meine, es gibt Gebiete,
die sind so ein bisschen
als am Arsch der Welt geplant.
So hier unten beispielsweise und so.
Da ist auch weniger los.
Aber hier, es ist überall was los.
Überall.
Das liegt natürlich auch daran,
dass du überall Zeugs hast.
Irgendwelche Materialien,
Notepunkte, irgendwelche Farben,
wo du Zeugs anbauen kannst und so.
Okay, dann verkaufe ich jetzt erstmal
den ganzen Krempel hier.
Ganzes Loot.
Ah ne, ich habe es schon rausgeholt.
Pass auf hier,
Highspeed-Teleport.
Bam, 6 Mille.
GG.
So, dann holen wir mal unseren,
liefern wir mal unseren Kamel ab,
holen unseren Gaul wieder raus.
Erdrückeberger 98,
die meisten Leute sind mit 56 überhaupt nicht in der Wüste.
Also bisher war es eigentlich so,
dass es in der Wüste relativ,
ich weiß nicht wie es mit dem aktuellen Patch ist,
ich habe jetzt eine Weile vorher nicht gespielt,
aber bisher ist in der Wüste eigentlich
relativ wenig los gewesen.
Vor allem, weil halt die ganzen Casual Bobs
halt ein bisschen Schiss vor der Wüste haben,
so nach dem Motto.
Da kannst du pick hard werden und gefährlich
und du verlierst Leben,
wenn du quasi kein Wasser dabei hast.
Eigentlich ist in den anderen Gebieten
fast genauso viel los.
Mehr los.
Die normalen Leute,
die nicht in die Wüste gehen.
Thousand Client,
hier unten im neuen Elfengebiet
sind wahrscheinlich, da war ich übrigens noch gar nicht,
so richtig, außer hier in der Stadt.
Gibt es ja auch ein paar gute Spots.
Die beliebtesten Ex-Spots sind
eigentlich hier,
je nachdem welches Gear und Level.
Einmal das hier,
ist saubeliebt.
Können wir gleich mal hinlatschen
und halt das Zeug hier.
Helms, Elwigs schreien
und hier unten diese komischen
Banditen und sowas, Mains.
Da leveln gerne viele Leute.
Gibt es eine Strafe
fürs Pick hard?
Reite mal Federwölfe, Max.
Ja, mache ich.
Wir reiten jetzt von, also ich zeige es euch mal.
Wir sind jetzt quasi auf der einen Seite der Map,
wobei das nicht ganz stimmt.
Wirklich Ende der Map,
da war ich noch gar nicht.
Man sieht es hier, hier sind auch Gebiete,
wo ich noch gar nicht gewesen bin.
Also hier hinter dieser Wüstenstadt,
hier ist dann das Meer
und hier ist nochmal so eine Küstenstadt.
Ich habe das selbst alles noch gar nicht aufgedeckt.
Also wir reiten jetzt von
Eingang zur Wüste
reiten wir jetzt mal
runter
zu
ins neueste Gebiet,
was mit dem letzten Patch gekommen ist.
War ich ja auch noch nicht, außer in der Startstadt.
Auf Max Settings,
ja das machen wir, das wollte ich eh machen.
Wir stellen jetzt nämlich nochmal Grafik um auf,
wir stellen jetzt Grafik mal Leute,
wir stellen es auf Ultra High.
Wir stellen, wir stellen es nicht nur auf,
wir stellen es nicht nur auf
Slightly High oder auf High
oder auf Very High,
wir stellen es auf Very High
und auf High End Mode.
Passt mal auf, jetzt geht es ab.
Das bringt sogar meinen Rechner
mit,
also ich habe ja nur wirklich,
du kannst ja eigentlich keinen besseren Rechner fürs Spielen kaufen aktuell.
Ähm, in Schweden, ja.
Distance Blur
wollen wir nicht.
Habt ihr es gesehen? Improved Distance?
Da hinten?
Dem ist eingeploppt.
Also man sieht,
es sieht schon deutlich besser aus.
Deutlich, deutlich besser, ne?
Man sieht ja auch,
das Popup ist jetzt halt auch gar nicht mehr ganz so extrem
zu sehen, aber
ich finde, wenn man darauf achtet, fällt es einem
sogar fast noch mehr auf.
Was, wenn er die Frage vorliest, gibt es eine Strafe für PKs?
Ach ja, ähm,
ja, bevor ich losreite, also Strafe für PKs,
je nachdem, wo du dich aufhältst.
Aber das Spiel sieht echt gut aus, ne?
Wenn man sich das jetzt mal anguckt, richtig gut.
80 FPS, ja, nur warte mal, wenn ich durch die Stadt
reite gleich. Ähm,
in der Wüste
gibt es andere Strafen als im restlichen Land
für PK.
Normalerweise ist es so,
wenn du jemanden PKst, verlierst du Karma-Punkte
und irgendwann,
je nachdem, wie gut deine Ausrüstung ist
und die Ausrüstung des Gegners, also wenn du jetzt
schwach ausgerüstet
weg PKst,
quasi umbringst, wenn man so will,
verlierst du viel mehr Karma,
als wenn du einen gleich, ähnlich gut
gegierten wie du killst.
Und wenn du negativ Karma
hast, kann dich die ganze
Welt
killen. Äh,
PK ist Player Kill.
Kann dich die ganze Welt killen.
Und, ähm, ich,
Fabian, vielleicht weißt du das,
ist das immer noch so, dass du, ähm,
Kristalle verlieren kannst, wenn du negativ Karma bist
und gekillt wirst? Außer in der Wüste.
Also, soweit ich weiß,
ist es nämlich so, dass du sogar, ähm,
wenn du gekillt wirst und negativ
Karma hast, also dich kann quasi
die ganze Welt killen,
dann kannst du sogar hier unten
kannst du
hier, äh, Kristalle von deinen
Items verlieren.
Also es hat schon, es hat schon Nachteile.
Ja, oder du, stimmt, oder wie es der Fabian
grad sagt, oder du gehst in den PvP-Chat.
Warte mal, ich mach mal das Pad weg,
das geht mir auf den Keks.
Piss dich, Alter. So, also wie gesagt,
wir reiten jetzt hier von Eingang Wüste runter in das
neue Elfengebiet.
Und wir gucken, wir können uns mal zwischendrin so ein paar Sachen
angucken,
die ich ganz cool finde, die so ein bisschen auf dem Weg
liegen. Also das erste, was wir sehen jetzt,
ist gleich die erste größere Stadt.
Ist, ist
Altinova, die kommt, da sieht man dann auch, da wird's
auch gleich ein bisschen ruckeln. Hier sind's
jetzt schöne 88 FPS in der Stadt,
werden's dann wahrscheinlich 40 sein.
Und man reitet.
Entweder kann man hier Auto,
Autoreiten machen, so wie ich hier gerade
anhab, dann reitet der automatisch. Oder man
kann halt manuell reiten.
Dann geht das Ganze auch ein bisschen schneller.
Kann auch noch ein bisschen Gas geben mit dem Pferd und
alles. Aber man sieht, Pop-Ups sind immer noch
krass, ja. Also Pop-Ups sind im Spiel
wenn du dich bewegst halt immer präsent so.
Aber es ist nicht mal ganz
so eklig wie auf
Low Settings. Aber eins muss man sagen, wenn man
hier langsam durchreitet und sich das anguckt,
die Spielwelt ist wirklich sehr hübsch.
Ein geiles T... Hey, das ist
das ist das T5-Pferd.
T5-Pferd, Fabian, ja.
Ich habe eine 1080 DI.
Das hier neben ist Rock
Outpost, oder wie dieses Ding heißt. Rock Post.
Da startet man
oftmals seine Grind-Ausflüge hier neben
zum Bashim-Spot.
Ist auch dick exp.
Guck mal. Ha! Da ist
ein Arbeiter vom Friseur
gerade rumgelaufen.
PC-Arbeiter. Ja, war
Gott, wart mal ab, bis ich nach Altinova reinreite.
Da sind meine FPS auch nicht mehr so gut.
Und das ist
halt wirklich sehr hübsch gemacht hier alles.
So, jetzt reiten wir hier nach
Altinova rein.
So erste größere Stadt,
die es hier auf dem Weg gibt.
Kannst du mal ein bisschen das Interface erklären, was willst du denn wissen?
Jetzt ist halt gleich
Nacht, was halt zum Weltzeigen
vielleicht nicht so toll ist, aber
sehen wir ja gleich.
Also die Spielwelt ist wirklich super gemacht.
Ach ja, und diese Schiffe da unten fahren wirklich
und da kann man drauf, ne?
Sieht man hier, sieht man
Schiffe hier, guck. Schiffsrouten.
Kann man drauf.
Man kann, ich halt mal kurz an, dass ihr mal seht
wie weit diese Weltmap geht. Man kann
wir reiten jetzt ja quasi nur
einmal in der Mitte lang. Also wir reiten
quasi von Wüste hier einmal runter
zu Elfstand. Das geht noch bis hier oben.
Also das hier ist
dieses Meeresgebiet, was wir
vor einigen Patches eingeführt haben.
Das ist halt für die ganzen krassen Fischer
und
Meeresmonster, Gilden,
Jäger und Typen halt interessant.
Geht bis hier oben. Hier oben ist die Map dann wirklich zu Ende.
So, und das ist das Gildenbanner der
jeweiligen Gilde, die
die Stadt gerade geclaimed hat, wo wir gerade beim
PvP-System sind.
Oder? Erzähl ich Mist?
Ja, na, würde schon sagen ist das.
Muss, müsste es eigentlich sein.
Jaja, hängt so oft hier rum.
So, und das ist halt Weihnachtsdekoration
gerade, oder Silvesterdekoration.
Das ist Altinova, das ist
eigentlich eine der zentralen...
Wow! Die World Map hat
übelst geruckelt gerade.
Ist eigentlich so eines der zentralen Städte.
Wie die Map
ruckelt, wenn ich sie aufmache.
Eines der zentralen Städte hier in dem Game.
So die Hauptstadt quasi
von dem oberen Teil,
wenn man es so will. Video Performance.
Ja, jetzt sieht man es mal. Guckt euch die FPS an.
Jetzt droppt es halt schon in der Stadt.
Und es sind zum
gerade auch zum größten Teil NPCs
und nur relativ wenig Spieler.
Guckt mal, da ist ein Arbeiter vor mir.
Und hier stehen, in Altinova stehen
hier vorne meistens die ganzen krassen Anglers
rum. Hier, da stehen sie.
Die Angler.
Ja, da wird geangelt.
Also, wer auf Crafting
und Angeln steht,
wird im Video glücklicher als mit dem
Angelsimulator 2018.
Weiter geht's.
So, Sonnenuntergang, sich auch sehr hübsch gemacht.
Und ihr kennt das ja
in vielen MMOs.
Es ist ja oft so, es gibt
Waldgebiete, Schneegebiete,
Wüstengebiete und sowas.
Aber der Übergang ist halt sehr
zackig immer.
Also in manchen MMOs hast du quasi
Wüstengebiet,
Waldgebiet, Schneegebiet
so nach dem Motto.
Und die BDO Map ist
ziemlich realistisch aufgebaut.
Also du reitest quasi nicht jetzt einfach
von der Wüste im Wald.
Sondern du reitest halt
von der Wüste dann erstmal
in so ein bisschen
quasi könnte man so mit dem Mittelmeer
vergleichen.
Dann reitest du halt durch normales Grünes
bis du unten in den Wald kommst.
Ach ja, und man kann hier überall hin, was man sieht.
Levelgrenzen sind erst
hier unten. Und ihr werdet sehen,
egal wo ich hinreite,
mal gucken, ob ich auf dem Channel bin, wo was los ist.
Ah, geht so.
Ihr werdet sehen, egal wo ich hinreite,
wo ich hingehe, sind überall
Spieler unterwegs.
Und das habe ich noch in keinem anderen MMO
gesehen,
dass sie das geschafft haben, dass die komplette
Map irgendwie bevölkert ist.
Wisst ihr was,
wir machen mal kurz einen Abstecher.
Wir machen mal kurz einen
Abstecher
zum
größten Casual Grind Spot
des Games.
Fabian, ist das noch, ist das hier oben immer noch
angesagt, ja?
Wir reiten jetzt mal hin.
Sausenspot, eines der berüchtigsten Sachen
im ganzen Game.
Wir reiten mal ein bisschen schneller.
Na, und für Leute, die gerne Quests machen
und nicht nur Mobs hauen,
ähm, es gibt an jeder Ecke auch
die üblichen MMO-Quests, die man
halt so kennt.
Und hier zahlt sich's wirklich aus, weil man kriegt
Energie und Contribution Points für
Map aufdecken und Quests erledigen.
Max wird gleich
PKt. Na, die Typen am
Sausenspot, ich glaube die meisten da PKn
glücklicherweise nicht so einfach.
Wir könnten Leute PKn am Sausenspot.
So, und ich find das ist wirklich
sehr hübsch gemacht hier.
Und während wir reiten,
man sieht ja auch, es gibt überall halt
diese, diese Nodes,
wo man sich für seine, seine Arbeiter
Unterkünfte kaufen kann und die können dann
für ein, beispielsweise,
wo hab ich hier was, hier
hab ich einen Arbeiter,
der baut für mich zum Beispiel
Kohle und
Rubine und
Zink und so Zeug
ab. Wofür braucht man
Energie und Contribution Points? Contribution
Points brauchst du genau für das, was ich hier gezeigt hab.
Äh, um
dir Unterkünfte
für Arbeiter zu mieten und so Sachen
und Pferdewagen und sowas
und
um spezielle Sachen aufzuleveln.
Also sprich, man könnte das hier
auch noch verbessern, diesen Node.
Dann droppen die Monster da mehr und so Dinger.
Da kann man Energie investieren. Energie
lädt sich wieder auf mit der Zeit.
Contribution Points
bleiben investiert, solange man halt
sich irgendwie was davon
gemietet hat. Mit Energie
kann man sich zum Beispiel bei seinem Black Spirit
auch, ähm,
XP-Boost abholen. Und
ja stimmt, stimmt, genau, ich hab's vergessen, was
einer im Chat grad geschrieben hat. Du brauchst Energie
natürlich auch, wenn du, ähm, Zeugs
abbauen willst.
Also wenn du farmst oder, oder
oder hier irgendwelche Büsche
ernten willst und sowas.
So, berüchtigster
XP-Spot in ganz BDO.
Thousand
Garrison, Thousand Spot.
Pass auf, jetzt ist, doch,
da sind, da sind sie schon, die ersten.
Ist doch nicht viel los grade.
Na doch, doch, doch, doch, hier ist viel
los. Schon, ja, ja.
Guck mal, an jeder Ecke, an jeder Ecke
sind sie hier. Das ist ihr
berüchtigster XP-Spot.
Wo da, wo auch viel
pickard wird. Einfach,
weil da wieder die üblichen Typen am Start
sind. Buddy, Spot is taken,
Spot is taken, please leave.
Und da werden sie halt pickard.
So, haben wir uns das angeguckt.
Dann reiten wir jetzt mal über Velia.
Ist quasi so die Hauptstadt, die ich
für mich auserkoren hab,
als dort, wo ich mein Geld
und Items lagere.
Reiten wir jetzt mal hin. Jetzt
kommen wir quasi von diesem, wir sind ja
eben von der Wüste quasi in so ein
so ein mediterranes Gebiet
geritten. Und jetzt
kommen wir langsam so in dieses,
wo, wo es wieder alles schön grün ist.
Velia ist quasi, quasi so ein bisschen
wie Venedig. Quasi
so eine Küstenstadt
mit
Häusern. Na, wobei, naja,
Venedig ist ein blödes, blödes Beispiel. Die haben ja viele
Häuser auf dem Wasser.
Ähm.
Ah, Küstenstadt
halt. So, und wenn wir jetzt mal hier so
am Rand reiten, das ist wirklich
verdammt hübsch gemacht. Ich hoffe, man sieht, Moment.
Also,
man kann hier so viel,
guck, da hinten ist, geht's aufs Meer raus.
Ich könnte jetzt, und das
geht halt wirklich in wenigen MMOs so,
so extrem, dass du dann auch wo Sinnvolles
hinkommst. Wenn ich jetzt ein Boot
dabei hätte, könnte ich jetzt da vorne ans,
ans, ans Wasser,
würde ich hier vorne ans Wasser gehen, würde mich ins Boot setzen
und hier gucken, was ist das für eine Insel.
Und da ist dann meistens auch irgendwas drauf.
Ja, sei es ein Note Manager,
wo ich wieder Arbeiter hinschicken kann, die für mich
Sachen abbauen, oder was auch immer.
Zwar nicht wirklich komplett
auf allem, aber auf den meisten Sachen.
Wo du dir ein Fischerboot kaufen kannst,
ich glaub, ich hab meins aus dem Marketplace.
Ja, oder wie der Fabian sagt,
selbst bauen.
Guck, da gibt's auch wieder Quests.
Schon alle nicht gemacht.
Ja, um jetzt mal zu zeigen, wie das mit dem Note Manager
dann funktioniert. Also, wenn ihr
das erste Mal eine Map aufdeckt,
und den Note Manager findet und mit dem redet,
dann wird
das halt hier
markiert auf der Map und dort kann man dann
Sachen machen, ja.
Also Arbeiter hinschicken,
oder den Note mit Energie aufleveln
für bessere Drops
und so Dinger.
Also einfach nur rumreiten bringt nichts, man muss
die Note Manager suchen.
Das hier finde ich ist halt auch wieder sehr hübsch gemacht.
Guck mal, das finde ich echt hübsch.
Ich mein, wir haben jetzt natürlich auch coole Lichtverhältnisse hier, ne?
Muss man ja auch mal sagen.
Das ist halt mit Sonnenuntergang
passt halt schon echt gut.
Sagt mal, wie sehr lohnt es sich
die Hauptwaffe aufzuwerten, wenn man eh nur
mit Awakening kämpft. Lohnt sich, weil
deine,
deswegen brauchst du auch da, also sollte auch da
das Ziel die Bosswaffe sein,
weil der Schaden deiner Hauptwaffe
einfließt in den Damage deiner Awakening
Waffe. Ja,
Skull Devil, da reiten wir letztendlich jetzt auch hin.
Wir reiten jetzt quasi durch die,
durch die, durch die
bekannte, durch das bekannte Gebiet runter in das
neue Gebiet. Das sieht halt
wirklich sehr cool aus hier.
Und auf den meisten
Inseln, die man da sieht, ne?
Seht ihr ja hier, wo ich gerade vorbeigehe. Diese Insel haben wir ja
gerade gesehen. Überall ist irgendwie was
drauf, wo sich's lohnt
hinzugehen.
Und sei es nur, dass
man dafür Energie oder Contribution Points kriegt.
Ich hab auch bei weitem
noch nicht alles aufgedeckt hier.
So, jetzt reiten wir erstmal nach Velia runter.
Ich glaube, als
das Spiel released wurde,
war, war das dieses Gebiet
hier. Oder Fabian? So dieses
Gebiet war, glaube ich, bei Release da.
Wo war ich noch gar nicht?
So das hier.
So, wir sehen schon, die Landschaft hat sich schon wieder
komplett geändert. Das ist hier halt grün.
Und wenn man sich die Daily Quests
von Black Spirit abholt, wo es
darum geht, irgendwelche Bosse zu killen, die sind auch
alle so in
diesem Gebiet hier dann.
So, sind wir in Velia.
In Velia stehen immer
viele Schiffe rum, weil
die Leute von hier losfahren.
Oh, wie es ruckelt. Video Performance
0, 3 FPS, macht ja
nichts. Menschliche Augen sieht ja eh nicht viel mehr.
Oh, immer
dieses dumme Gelaber, Max, ey.
Es ist schon nicht mehr lustig,
ey. So dumm.
Immer der gleiche
scheiß Witz.
So, ähm.
Ja, weil die meisten fahren dann halt von
hier los, wenn sie irgendwo hin, wenn sie hin wollen.
Hier ist ein super XP-Spot.
Sau beliebt.
Pirate Island.
Da bist du halt ein bisschen unterwegs von Velia
mit dem Schiff. Und wie gesagt, du
kannst, theoretisch kannst du von Velia losfahren
bis hier oben hin
und unterwegs kannst du krasse
Fisch-Actions machen.
Oder aber du nimmst eine dieser
Schiffsrouten, die es auch so gibt.
Die fahren dann von hier irgendwo los oder so.
Musst also auch von Velia hin.
Okay.
So.
Es ist ein bisschen schade, dass jetzt wieder
ein Arbeiter vom Fall wäre. Ein bisschen schade, dass
jetzt grad Nacht wird.
Aber guckt euch mal, wie das Meer aussieht.
Das ist wirklich sehr hübsch gemacht hier, ne?
Okay, das Meer ist vielleicht
ein bisschen sehr rot jetzt.
Und das ist so meine Hauptstadt, wo ich hier, guckt,
wo ich hier im, im Wald
mein ganzes Zeugs drinne liegen hab.
So. Weiter geht's.
Gibt es Schnellreise?
Nein. Oder zumindest nur sehr beschränkt.
Es gibt ein paar Items,
da kannst du dich teleportieren.
Aber die sind einmal Use
und teuer.
Also eigentlich, nein, gibt keine Schnellreise.
Deswegen ist es auch ganz praktisch,
wenn du mehrere Helden hast,
die du an, an, an,
die nicht deine Mains sind oder so,
die du an
Hotspots abgestellt hast, ja.
Zum Beispiel hier neben
ist der Boss
für die Awakening-Waffen.
Wenn man dann einen Held abstellt, dann kann man da immer
mit draufhauen, wenn er spawnt.
So. Und es gibt
noch eine Schnellreise-Funktion, die ist aber nicht
schnell. Man kann jetzt zum Beispiel
sagen, ich möchte diesen Charakter
transportieren
nach, ähm,
äh, Sandcrane-Basar.
Das ist da, wo wir losgeritten sind eben. Aber
in der Zeit, wo der transportiert
wird, muss ich auf einen anderen Held
umloggen und kann den eine Stunde lang
quasi nicht spielen.
Wenn ich den, wenn ich ihn einlogge, dann ist er nicht
transportiert.
So. Reiten wir mal weiter.
Wir wollten ja ins neue Gebiet.
Wir reiten nochmal hier unten
durch, wo ist denn das Teil, wo muss ich denn hin?
Ja, da reiten wir durch.
Ups.
Das ist die größte, größte
Stadt hier in dem, in dem alten Bereich
der Map, wo eigentlich auch immer
was los. Man sieht hier in Velia ist auch immer
was los. Wohlgemerkt,
man darf nicht vergessen, wenn man die Spieler immer
sieht hier, ähm, es ist hier
schon relativ viel los. Allerdings,
wir sind nur auf einem Channel von so
vielen. Und das ist wieder
hier eine Sache, wo ich denke,
wo man gut dran sieht, dass das
Spiel zur Zeit
fast schon boomt.
Äh, Olvia
sind die Einsteiger-Channels.
Also, wo man startet,
wenn man neu ist.
Ich hab da gar keinen Zutritt drauf auf diese Server mehr.
Und
die Starter-Channels sind quasi
Overrun schon.
Wo ist Boss Zarka? Äh,
hier unten irgendwo, oder war das
Masken?
Doch, hier. Ah, da unten, hier unten ist er.
Da ist Zarka.
So. Wir sind jetzt aus
Velia rausgeritten.
Und reiten mal Richtung
Calcyon.
Und hier
startet man in der Ecke.
Also, wenn man einen neuen Charakter erstellt, startet man
hier oben.
Und der Weg führt einen quasi dann
erstmal hier von Olvia runter zu
Western Guard Camp und dann nach Velia.
Wir sehen hier jetzt allerdings in dem Gebiet
kaum Noobs rumrennen.
Aber, wie gesagt,
wir sehen sogar in diesem Teil der
Welt. Und das finde ich halt echt geil.
Das habe ich in noch keinem anderen MMO gesehen. Ihr habt es gerade gesehen.
Sogar hier kommen mir noch aktiv Spieler
entgegen, die irgendwas machen.
Und sei es nur traden oder so.
Wenn wir jetzt, wenn wir Zugang hätten
auf einen Olvia-Server,
würde das, wäre das hier
überrannt mit Low-Level-Charts.
Hat das Spiel eine richtige
Story? Ja, ganz ehrlich, aber ich habe sie nicht gelesen.
Es gibt eine
Main Quest,
dass der Held ist irgendwie
der König von Valencia oder irgendwie sowas.
Keine Ahnung, fragt mich in der Story.
Guckt da hier, Low-Level.
Da hat gerade mit dem...
Oh, einen neuen Chart hat er sich erstellt.
Hier geht es zum World Boss rauf.
Ja, oder?
Nicht, dass ich Mist erzähle. Ja, genau.
Guckt, überall sind Spieler am Start.
Obwohl das hier das Low-Level-Gebiet
schlechthin ist.
Es gibt kein Low-Level-
Low-Leveliges Gebiet als hier so oben
quasi. Und in dem Spiel ist die Nacht
auch nicht wirklich sacke dunkel, sondern sieht
auch cool aus.
Irgendwelche Trade-Typen, die hier rumlaufen.
Was sie halt auch gut geschafft haben,
ist, die Welt kommt sich wirklich
belebt vor. Oder lebhaft.
Glaubhaft, lebhaft.
Kommt einem die Welt vor.
Wieder irgendein Trade.
Ey.
Nein, nein, ich mach das jetzt nicht.
Ich mach das jetzt nicht. Der Fabian weiß,
was ich gerade vorhatte.
Da bin ich ja bekannt für.
Fabian, kennst du das noch?
Hahaha.
Player Wubblos.
So.
Also, wenn man der
Main-Quest folgt,
wird man hier auch an diese ganzen
Orte geschickt.
Und wird ein bisschen mit der Spielwelt
vertraut gemacht.
Also, hier oben ist auch eine Quest.
Hier oben kann man dann drauf. Muss irgendwelche
Harpien bashen.
Und es ist auch zu empfehlen, das zu machen.
Und sich anzugucken, weil, wie gesagt,
hier gibt es überall Nodes.
Und Knowledge von Mobs.
Also sprich, wenn man
Monster sucht und killt,
da gibt es
so einen Monster-Atlas.
Und wenn man den quasi komplett hat,
kriegt man auch wieder Contribution Points
und sowas. Oder Energie.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Man kriegt zumindest was, was man braucht.
Also, selbst mal angenommen,
ihr seid jetzt in dem Game neu,
durchgerusht auf 56.
Geht ja auch saumäßig schnell, ja.
Und ihr sagt, okay, ich will mir einfach ein bisschen
die Welt angucken. Ihr habt was von.
Also, ihr geht jetzt beispielsweise dahin
und basht diese Mobs. Dann kriegt ihr
Knowledge von diesen Mobs.
Und dafür kriegt ihr Energie, was ihr wieder
investieren könnt für bessere Sachen.
Oder zum
Gathern, zum Ernten, zum sonst was.
Also,
das ist nicht einfach nur sinnlos groß,
die Welt, sondern
bringt fast jeder
Winkel auch was.
Hier wird man auch
langgeführt bei Low-Level-Quests.
Bei der Windmühle.
Die hat gerade ein bisschen rumgespackt.
So, jetzt reiten wir mal in die alte Hauptstadt.
Da ruckelt es immer.
Wenn man nur in die
Nähe kommt, hat man nur noch 60 FPS.
Hallo, Captain Canaria.
Ich meine, es ist halt
Nacht gerade.
Sieht jetzt nicht so geil aus, wie es aussehen könnte, aber
selbst hier ist noch
was los.
Guck hier, Spieler. Alle Spieler.
Also, nicht das hier jetzt,
so die weißen Punkte auf der
Map. Also, es ist auch wirklich
alte Gebiete, wo eigentlich
nichts mehr zu holen wäre in anderen MMOs
für High-Level-Spieler.
Ist noch was los.
Da ist schon wieder ein Arbeiter
von Fabian. Der ist wirklich überall
zu Gange.
Was ist die neue Hauptstadt? Naja, was heißt neu?
Oh,
das lag in der Stadt. Ich zeige es dir nachher.
Also, da, wo wir eben
durchgelaufen sind. Entweder Altinova
oder Valencia in der Wüste.
Also, was heißt Hauptstadt?
Also, die jeweilige Gebiet-Hauptstadt meine ich damit.
So eine Hauptstadt vom Spiel an sich
gibt es ja nicht. Je nachdem, in welchem
Gebiet du bist.
So, jetzt bin ich einmal
in irgendwie den Thronraum geritten.
Was auch immer ich jetzt hier mache, außer, dass
Weihnachtsdekoration da ist.
So, jetzt reiten wir weiter. Wir sind hier immer noch
auf unserem Weg ins neue Gebiet und ein paar Sachen
dazwischen drinnen anzugucken.
Alter!
BDO-Performance!
Reiten wir mal...
Wo reiten wir mal durch?
Äh, wo ist denn Heidel nochmal?
Wo war denn der Kram? Hier?
Ne, da reiten wir nicht durch. Das ist die falsche Richtung.
Da hätten wir uns die
größten AFK-Fischerhorn
angucken können des Games. Die stehen hier unten
immer rum.
Doch, die lags sind seit einem der letzten Patches, wenn man
die World Map aufmacht.
Wir sind auf dem Weg, ja.
Jetzt kommen wir gleich ins
Waldgebiet. Wir reiten mal durch
den Wald jetzt.
Wenn wir zurück reiten,
wir müssen ja auch noch zurück.
Wenn wir zurück reiten, reiten wir
den anderen Weg. Dann reiten wir hier rum
durch Heidel
durch und hier unten lang.
Gucken wir uns
den anderen Weg an. Wir sind ja quasi eben
so geritten. Dann reiten wir so.
Ja, jetzt ist Nacht.
Nachts
sind die Monster stärker
und geben auch mehr XP.
Aber ich find sogar nachts ist die Welt wirklich
hübsch. Aber die
Knotenpunkte auf Level 10 bringt solche
Erträge, oder?
Was meinst du? Also Knotenpunkte auf
Level 10 bringt,
ich hab mal gelesen, statistisch
gesehen nicht so sonderlich viel
Handwand.
Das Game läuft eigentlich auf den meisten
Rechnern. Allerdings
musst du halt die Grafik
darunter stellen.
Hier ist auch ein Spot sehr beliebt
zum Geld sammeln und
leveln.
Bei
loweren, also mit Level
50 oder so auf der anderen Seite.
Catfish Spot.
Ne, WWPD, was war da?
Finde alle 30 Stunden
mal ein Buch.
Hallo?
Ich hatte am Anfang der Woche
irgendwie zwei Scrolls
und hab jetzt quasi
nur durch Naga grind
die letzten zwei Tage 1, 2, 3,
4, 5 Scrolls und hab hier unten
nochmal 1, 2, 3, 4 Scrolls
gemacht. Und das ist noch wenig.
So, jetzt reiten wir in den Wald rein.
Da muss ich euch jetzt auch gleich mal den
dümmsten NPC zeigen, den es in dem ganzen
Game gibt.
Also nicht hier drinnen.
Sondern
ich glaub in Trent ist der.
Zimmer im Wald.
Auch an den
Wanscha-Spots hier früher
hab ich beim Fabian gesehen im Stream,
wie er da abgegangen ist und alle möglichen
Wanscha-Warrior im Wald massakriert hat.
Guter Spot für Exp und Geld,
wenn man ein bisschen lower im Level ist.
So, und jetzt reiten wir halt komplett in den Wald rein.
Und was
auch cool gemacht haben ist,
die Welt ist wirklich groß und
abwechslungsreich und halt
komplex irgendwo.
Aber sie haben es trotzdem
geschafft, dass es so viele markante Punkte
gibt, dass du dich
zurecht findest. Ich mein,
guck mal, ich hab kaum, ich hab noch, ich war
hier an den meisten Spots 1, 2 mal und trotzdem
weiß ich nur ungefähr was, wo was ist.
Ist halt echt cool.
Du kannst dir halt einfach
gut merken in dem Game, wo was ist, obwohl die
Weltkarte so groß ist.
Oje, WWPD, das klingt nach
YouTube-Twitch-Drama-Deluxe.
Wieder irgendein Typ vorbeigegangen.
Jetzt sind wir halt mitten im Wald.
Was und was
bringen diese Bücher? Die brauchst du für Memory
Fragments.
Gehst du hin, killst Mobs, kriegst du Memory Fragments.
Memory Fragments brauchst du zum Upgraden
von deinem Bossgear.
Äh, der Pazifist,
das hat ne gewisse Komplexität,
ich check das auch nicht.
Also nicht wirklich gut.
Du kannst quasi, dieses Node
und Handelssystem ist ein komplett eigenes Spiel
im Spiel, wenn man so will. So, ich zeig euch
mal den dümmsten NPC überhaupt.
Richtig hängen geblieben, der
Typ, ey.
Vor allem, wenn man hier länger steht, klatscht
der die ganze Zeit, das ist
abartig nervig.
Easy Clap.
So, jetzt reiten wir runter ins neue
Elfengebiet. Da können
wir jetzt mal ein bisschen zusammengucken, weil wie gesagt,
ich war da noch gar nicht großartig.
Wo ist denn die Hauptstadt?
Wo ist denn hier unten die Hauptstadt?
Kennt sich da jemand aus? Wo muss ich da hin?
Was, oben beim Baum?
Da?
Rechts vom Polyforest, okay.
Also,
da, oder was?
Da ist die Hauptstadt.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob wir die gleich finden.
So, und auch,
auch wenn wir jetzt einmal
quasi quer, schräg über die Welt gerannt
sind, die Welt
ist an sich ja noch viel größer. Wie gesagt, hier oben
gibt's noch das Meer, hier hinter der Wüste
geht's auch noch weiter. Ich glaub, hier oben ist
auch noch irgend... zumindest
noch ein bisschen was.
Hier unten ist noch nix. Da kommt mal
irgendwann wahrscheinlich ein Schneegebiet, vermutet
man.
Weil das ist das einzige, was es so noch nicht gibt.
Es schneit.
Yeah.
Wie schweinachtlich hier.
Ja, gucken wir mal,
ob wir hier die neue Hauptstadt
finden, von dem Gebiet.
Aber jetzt ist erst mal
Scheißwetter angesagt.
Äh, Drückeberger 98, ich glaube,
du kriegst aber von den
Scrolls aus der Wüste von den Mobs
im Durchschnitt mehr Memory
Fragments. Oh, jetzt sind wir
hier im Elfengebiet angekommen.
Und jetzt reiten wir mal weiter und versuchen mal
die Hauptstadt zu finden.
Ach Quatsch, ne, wir sind noch gar nicht angekommen, WTF.
Wir sind erst
am Eingang.
Null.
Auf, reit los.
Und ich find, selbst
nachts ist cool gemacht. Ich mein, das sieht doch hier
echt mega atmosphärisch aus,
finde ich. Wenn man sich das mal anguckt, hier
Mond, irgendwie Schnee auf den Bäumen und so,
ist echt cool.
Also, grafisch ist das schon sehr, sehr nice.
Freund, Opossum TS.
Und
ihr seht, wie lange das dauert, einmal über die Map
zu reiten.
Schnellreise gibt's nicht. Also,
da ist man schon ein bisschen beschäftigt.
Ein bisschen beschäftigt. Man muss aber auch dazu sagen,
ich hab ein scheiß Pferd.
Der Fabian
ist wahrscheinlich mit seinem Pferd
keine Ahnung, in 10 Minuten einmal über die Map
geritten oder so.
So, hier oben ist angeblich
jetzt die Hauptstadt irgendwo. Die suchen wir jetzt.
Jetzt ist
ein Boss gespawnt, da könnten wir jetzt hingehen.
Wobei, also wir könnten da nicht hingehen, weil wir sind
zu weit weg. Der ist, weiß gar nicht,
wo der ist, hier irgendwo?
Gute Frage. Bei dem war ich noch nie.
Hey, Schnee ist
weg.
Guck mal, was, ne Weitsicht, hä?
Richtig nice.
Noch gleich mal nur noch 60 FPS.
Das ist übrigens das
Gebiet, wo ich im, wo ich beim
Silvester,
nicht Silvester, ähm,
das war anders, wo ich abends mal
Livestream gemacht hab
vor einer Weile, wo wir
ein bisschen BDO gecrindled haben. Das war hier rechts.
Im neuen
Gebiet. Man sieht, hier sind auch schon
ein bisschen mehr Spieler unterwegs jetzt.
Reiten wir jetzt mal hier runter.
Auf dem Pferd.
Ich mein, das sieht schon echt nice aus.
Vor allem jetzt halt hier so, wenn's Nacht ist, ne?
Das hat schon fast so
ein bisschen Witcher-Feeling, so hier.
Ich mein, das sieht doch wirklich gut aus.
Also bis das, bis halt auf das
Aufploppen, weil halt BDO technisch
an mancher Stelle schon noch ganz schön ne Krücke ist.
Aber ich find, das sieht
echt mega nice aus hier.
Wieso spielst du nicht mit dem Friseur,
weil er grad AFK Essen ist?
Wir haben vorhin ein bisschen gelevelt.
Äh, beste
Findung aller Zeiten.
Was machen die Mammutels da? Die stehen rum,
warten bis gebasht werden.
So, und ich hoffe, wir kommen jetzt in der neuen Hauptstadt
hier unten raus vom neuen Gebiet. Wie gesagt, ich war
noch nicht da. Ich verlasse mich da auf euch.
Irgendjemand hat gesagt,
hier neben dem Spot ist die angeblich.
Gucken wir mal, ob die da auch wirklich
ist. Aber das neue Gebiet
sieht wirklich hübsch aus.
Oh, guck mal, da oben, da ist was.
Da oben auf dem Bash, habt ihr das gesehen?
Ne, da ist doch nix.
Bisschen weiter
rechts. Also quasi hier so.
Da, da so.
An welchem Spot
sollte man grinden, wenn man 56 ist?
Also die einzigen Spots, die ich
noch so kenne, ist hier so. Da.
Ups.
Stehen ja auch dabei was für APs.
Helms oder hier unten.
Ah.
Kommt aber drauf an, wie viel
Attack
und Defense du hast.
Bald 90%.
Guck mal, da oben ist die Stadt. Wir haben
diese gefunden.
Das sieht jetzt halt schon eher aus wie so das 0815
Fantasy-Welt, ne?
Muss aber auch mal sein.
Sonst ist die BDO-Welt
ja recht realistisch gehalten.
Wo ist denn der Note-Manager?
Stable?
Wo ist denn der Note-Manager
Dude hier für?
Suchen wir mal.
Wo der Note-Manager ist.
Hier ist viel Zeug.
Storage-Keeper.
Jetzt haben wir was aufgedeckt.
Was ist denn der Note-Manager hier
von?
Braucht man glaub ich gar nicht, ne?
So, nice.
Wir haben's gefunden.
Sieht aus wie aus Herr der Ringe. Ja, das soll ja wohl auch die
Elfen-Hauptstadt sein.
Ich find das Ding ist auch echt nice gelungen.
Da rennen sie rum und klatschen sinnlos.
Klatschanimationen haben die generell
wahnsinnig gerne
allen NPCs verpasst.
Hier stehen in dem Game so viele NPCs
rum. Easy Clap, Easy Clap,
Easy Clap, Easy Clap.
So.
Und nun zeig ich euch mal das
Schnellreise-System.
Was keins ist.
Ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel sagen
Dazu muss man übrigens nicht
aufs Pferd. Ich kann jetzt übrigens
sagen, transportiere mir mal
den Wubbler
zurück da wo wir
losgelaufen sind.
Obwohl, jetzt ist die Frage.
Wollt ihr,
dass ich nochmal zurückreite?
Oder reicht's jetzt?
Ich denke eigentlich es reicht.
Ich mein man hat die Welt ja ganz gut jetzt gesehen.
Ob wir jetzt so rum
geritten sind oder so rum
das macht jetzt in dem Gebiet auch nicht
großartig fett, ja.
Ich bin auch mal auf das Schneegebiet, bin ich echt mal gespannt.
Sollte das kommen.
Reicht ja, denk ich auch.
So, dann machen wir jetzt nämlich hier
Schnelltransport, nicht Schnellreise,
aber Transport zum Bazar
zurück und wir wechseln auf den Bersin.
So, und jetzt ist es so,
wenn ich das mache,
dann lockt er um
auf den Bersin
und ich kann jetzt meinen Wizard eine Stunde,
also, beziehungsweise doch, ich kann schon, aber
ich darf meinen Wizard eine Stunde nicht spielen,
sonst wird er nicht transportiert.
Also das ist ganz praktisch, wenn ich
einen Held von A nach B bewegen will
und mit einem anderen eine Stunde
was mache. Ich ja muss sagen,
das sieht doch echt hübsch aus hier in Velia, ne?
Lettern wir mal aufs Dach.
Will er nicht.
Das sieht doch echt cool aus.
Mein Wizard, meinst
das hier, ähm,
der sieht überhaupt nicht so aus, der hat
bloß das Bild nicht aktualisiert.
Ihr habt ihn doch vorhin gesehen, der ist jung
und hat grüne Haare.
So, 360 down
the roof.
Das war es im Endeffekt.
Mehr kann ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen.
Oh, die Katze, die müssen wir retten.
Verlorene Katze, das können wir
so nicht lassen.
Der Berser rettet jetzt die Katze.
Moment.
Wie?
Katze, du wirst jetzt gerettet.
Die will nicht.
Die will sich
nicht retten lassen.
Man kann die Lost Cat noch nicht mal retten.
Ist bestimmt Teil von irgendeiner Quest.
Es gibt ganz viele Lost Cats.
Hallo?
Wow.
So, Leute.
Anschluss für heute.
Wen können wir denn noch hosten?
Irgendjemand, der
Overwatch spielt, den man noch
hosten könnte.
Nicht so wirklich, ne?
Weil
Season ist ja heute vorbei.
xQc.
Nee, xQc muss ich nicht hosten.
xQc hat 8000 Zuschauer.
Dann werde ich wahrscheinlich jetzt keinen hosten.
Den kenn ich,
der macht Siege-Videos.
Ich mach jetzt Schluss.
Reicht ja heute.
Und dann haben wir wieder gestartet.
Ich bin schon sehr betrieben.
Zeit mal her. Mal gucken.
2.30 Uhr und jetzt nochmal 2.30 Uhr.
5 Stunden.
Das ist doch echt sehr ordentlich.
Ja, dann macht's gut.
Bis morgen oder so.
Tschüss.